lately banks have been pulling back
funding from porn companies so JPMorgan
Chase is now involved in a lawsuit with
MRG entertainment which is a porn
company they don't want to back porn
anymore because of quote moral reasons
now I'm pretty sure that everyone
watches porn I've done a little research
on this and yeah everyone watches porn
most people don't have a problem with it
but there still seems to be this
morality attached to it which I really
just don't understand anymore because
porn has become so mainstream so is this
just like old school ridiculousness
I mean I mean the thinking from the bank
I don't want to say I understand both
sides because I really don't understand
where the banks are coming from I think
the only real valid argument the banks
could make if I'm gonna play devil's
advocate is that so many banks have
recently come under fire for doing kind
of like bad trading and for doing you
know for doing general unethical I'm
being like you doesn't necessarily have
the means to pay back the loan or not
just yet there's the the mortgage crisis
with the with the housing bubble but
also some like you know offshore kind of
involvement whole area so they can do
sort of financially irresponsible and
immoral things but when it comes to sex
I mean that's much more unethical and I
would see if there was a heightened fear
about record-keeping or whatever that
that might play into it but that's not
why they're not doing this they're not
doing this because they're saying that
there's some sort of [ __ ] morality
clause and it's probably just one guy
who doesn't feel comfortable you know
the president of that specific branch
weirdest porn and by the way he's the
guy who's looking up like snuff monkey
Dunkey porn at like acid trip like he's
watching at home Monkey document fun
this because I'm creepy I don't know if
you don't want to be involved
financially and legally if you don't
want to be tied to a company that is
doing things that aren't legal but the
porn industry is legal yeah this is a
profession business
and they should have the same treatment
of every potential client especially
when they're dealing with government
bailout money when they're dealing with
government funding when they're no
longer a completely private entity they
need to be you know obeying these kind
of fair lending yeah does this kind of
thing seem crazier now because porn has
become so mainstream I mean people are
literally making porn right now in their
bedroom with a webcam and it's so it's
just out there all the time we could all
have access to porn right this set we
could all be watching porn ridiculous is
that now we just we all know that people
watch porn it's a fourteen billion
dollar industry most like legitimate
porn companies have made a lot of money
if you're a bank you're probably making
a mistake not lending to one that has
its books and orders and it's numbers in
order because they're thriving and
they're not going anywhere so it's kind
of silly just from like a capitalistic
standpoint for a bank to financially to
say you know porn is not what we're
going back there's no money in porn
that's just ridiculous and foolish for
somebody but you know they're lending
money to Tobacco Firearms spirits
alcohol companies that make stuff with
GMO pesticides I mean the list goes on
and on to people that they regularly
lend money to openly that are actually
really hurting people and there's
actually clear and present danger for
using those products yeah and there's no
problem with that but porn which is what
is it I mean we could talk about this
could be this could be every show for
the rest of the year but what is it
fundamentally about sex because you're
right there's all these things that we
all know are far worse fear I mean I
have to interject and I'm not changing
the subject at all but I feel like oh I
can bring it back my particular viewers
would be upset with me if I didn't say
that I disagree with you about adding
GMO to that list but moving on from
there I personally think that you know
coming from a religious background and
and sort of being able to empathize with
individuals who are religious in that
way even though I disagree with them I
think there's kind of a fear of judgment
that comes from the sex stuff there's
like a shame component tied to it that's
different than a lot of these other
there should be a shame component tied
to most of those things that that's true
and so the issue I think is that oh well
if we back this if we're involved with
this the
how are we gonna be perceived from the
outside I don't think it's an intrinsic
moral issue I think it's it's a fear of
retribution and it's a shame thing my
big question here is is this against the
law I mean I don't know the legality of
it I think it is there are fair lending
laws in place and I may have a legal
operation that's not violating anything
your papers are in order you have your
whether it's your LLC your s car people
have that in order and you're being
denied a loan just based on morality
there are certain companies that have a
Johnson & Johnson's morality clauses
third for their employees or sign a
contract signed agree right this is
involuntary the lawsuit is saying that
they're violating their own contract and
now you're doing because it's a fair
lending practices and once you start
violating that based on it then it's
again a slippery slope thing and you can
just say you know we don't like your
past so we're not gonna loan to you you
at one point we're a stripper so now you
can't get a home loan it's completely
different than like a private restaurant
who says that they reserve the right not
to serve somebody and even then we've
seen a lot of lawsuits coming out even
though there are some laws kind of
protecting private institutions from
doing that but a bank that's almost
completely public at this point I think
yeah is gonna be have stricter laws kind
of that they have to uphold that yeah
you know it's funny what I was looking
at this story it was reminding me of did
you guys see boogie nights and you know
Don Cheadle plays Bach who is a porn
star who his whole dream is to start
this small business and then you can't
get the yeah he wants to start a stereo
business he can't get the money because
they see he's important he ends up
getting it in a shadier way it also
reminds me and I know that this seems
off-topic but in my way I'm drawing kind
of a parallel here when you look at kids
who have drug offenses kids who have
been arrested for you know smoking a
joint they can no longer get government
aid to be able to attend college like
these are the kids who probably made it
I was a high school teacher for at-risk
kids I'm in high school that I taught at
was for children that have been thrown
out of their other high schools and
usually it was for smoking cigarette
smoking some of them were no longer
allowed to attend public school and have
access to public education because they
got caught with pot yeah and I mean the
interesting thing is that these are
governmental practices and these are
laws that in place that are in place but
what happens what ends up happening is
it's like a self-propagating issue
because the people who need to help the
moe
are the people who are turned away and I
think that you're right a lot of these
people who work in these industries are
working very hard to prove that they
have a legitimate practice going on you
know which in the state I was teaching
that's really gone it's complete legal
it's not prostitution it's not it's not
human sex trafficking it's something
that's completely legal accessible and
most of the country and most people not
only watch it but enjoy it
but it's not Shane it has this veil of
shame across it all right I think we
nailed that one we were pretty clear
porn and sex authorities apartment
[Music]